forte présence militaire à savez dans le
centre du pays
hier l'armée est intervenue suite à des
mobilisations d'opposants au président
patrice talon
depuis le début de la semaine nombreux
sont les rassemblements et les barrages
routiers dans le nord et le centre du
bénin et ce jeudi les premières victimes
tombant d'ailleurs reçu un cap de tcl ce
matin à balles réelles et ces cas de
blessés par balles réelles
dans tous ces cas là tu as deux blessés
ont été orientés roi été transféré à
l'hôpital deux hommes s'avérer des
militants qui déplore le manque
d'opposition dans la course à la
présidence certains étant en exil ou
condamnés à des peines les rendant
inéligible
autre raison invoquée des dossiers de
candidatures incomplet
les seuls opposants peu connu du grand
public sont les anciens députés
alassane soumanou et corentin cool j'ai
fait 2 0
il va avec l'attak a tous répondre et
vous prépare déjà cela vous plaît
passicos logiquement affaires résultats
de 90% nous n'avons pas fait cela
si celui ci dénoncent une élection qui
risque d'être tronquée pour les
contestataires il ne serait pas un
véritable opposant de plaisance autant
il est en compétition avec un puck deux
candidats qui sont au fait des fûts de
figuratif
nous ne veux pas que cela
servant de fait valoir de marionnettes
pour cautionner l'élection du compte
environ patrice talon qui faisait
pourtant figure d'exemple démocratique
en un an sont initialement ne vouloir
faire qu'un mandat unique s'est
finalement ravisé
arrivé au pouvoir en 2000 16 l'homme
d'affaires ancien magna du coton s'est
peu à peu imposée mais malgré cela le
bilan économique est positif de plus de
60 au paiement qui à travers concerts
dans ce pays des finances publiques
assainies de nombreux services publics
digitalisées construction de routes et
développement de la production de coton
refusons de confiner sa population
malgré le coronavirus l'économie du pays
a pu maintenir une croissance positive
en 2020
mais si patrice talon est plébiscité
chez certaines élites il l'est beaucoup
moins par les classes populaires avec
38% de la population béninoise encore
sous le seuil de pauvreté
les cinq années de patrice talon à la
tête du pays n'ont pas été convaincantes
pour tous rendez-vous pris pour dimanche